le 16 avril vers 19 heures la terre
gronde à et des pannes d'électricité
affectèrent de nombreuses villes c'est
au grand jour seulement que le
gouvernement réalise à l'amplitude et
l'étendue des dégâts causés par ce
tremblement les villes de porto viejo
pedernales s manta et khanh hoà furent
parmi les plus touchées
mais le fait que le tremblement de terre
se produisent à la fin de la journée
juste avant que les habitants à se
coucher permis d'épargner de nombreuses
avec une magnitude 7,8 sur l'échelle de
richter
ce fut le tremblement de terre le plus
puissant de l'année 2016 et en equateur
le séisme le plus important depuis 1979
le président rafael correa a déclaré
l'état d'urgence et dépêché à 13500
membres de l'armée des forces de police
et des pompiers
je suis responsable de la zone qui a été
le plus touché
une zone commerciale en pleine activité
au moment où s'est déroulée la tragédie
les secouristes sont arrivés sur tous
les points critiques pendant les deux
premières heures les pompiers se sont
déplacés dans toute la zone et ont
réussi à sauver des victimes il y a eu
beaucoup de survivants
puis il a fallu chercher les corps sans
vie
on dénombra plus de 600 décès dans les
province de manabi et esmeraldas et au
total plus de 6000 blessés landes est
arrivé quand j'étais chez moi je pouvais
voir la montagne se soulever vers le
haut j'ai aussi vu bouger une partie des
bâtiments de la ville
j'ai vu les maisons en face se levaient
s'affaisser et se relever
[Musique]
pedernales s se trouve tout près du
point de jonction des plaques
cette ville de 40000 habitants fut
particulièrement touchés et beaucoup de
ces édifices sur complètement détruit
[Musique]
notre maison était composée de cinq
étages quand les répliques se sont
arrêtés j'avais perdu cinq membres de ma
famille ma soeur de 17 ans est toujours
sous le choc elle a vu le bâtiment
s'effondrer un entier et ma mère a vu
l'effondrement d'un bâtiment de 16
étages derrière moi dont il ne reste
plus rien il a été entièrement détruits
sur le coup
près de trente mille personnes se
retrouvèrent sans abris l'eau le gaz et
l'électricité furent coupés dans de
nombreux endroits et des centaines de
kilomètres de routes furent détruits
beaucoup ont perdu leur gagne pas la
douleur qui restera toujours c'est celle
ci des années de travail des cheveux en
moins des cheveux blancs tout est parti
il ne reste plus rien avec la physique
on ne peut pas tricher la structure
s'est vrillé au niveau du troisième et
du quatrième étage
[Musique]
l'équateur bahia et toute cette région
est une zone sismique extrêmement active
à travers l'histoire nous avons eu des
épisodes sismiques et ce n'est pas fini
cela n'est pas près de changer nous
voyons aux états unis ou en europe de
grand building et nous voulons nous
baser sur le même modèle mais ici c'est
différent
nous devons revenir à nos racines à nos
valeurs ancestrales le bois le roseau le
bambou pour vivre d'une manière durable
et respectueuse de l'environnement et
pour qu'il y ait moins deux morts